[Applause]
sometimes the simplest questions have
the most amazing answers like how can
trees be so tall it's a question that
doesn't even seem like it needs an
answer trees just are tall some of them
are over a hundred meters Why should
there be a height limit I'll tell you
why
trees need to transport water from their
roots up until their topmost branches in
order to survive and that is no trivial
task there is a limit to the height that
water can be sucked up a tube it's 10
meters if you suck on a long vertical
straw the water will go no higher than
10 meters at this point there'll be a
perfect vacuum at the top of the straw
and the water will start to boil
spontaneously for a tree to raise water
a hundred meters it would have to create
a pressure difference of 10 atmospheres
how would trees do that when I posed
this conundrum a lot of people said the
answer is transpiration and that's when
water evaporates from the leaf pulling
up the water molecules behind it and
that's clearly a mechanism a tree can
use to create suction but it doesn't
help us overcome this 10 meter limit
below as the pressure can go as a pure
vacuum which I imagine is not happening
instead of tree leaves right right Hank
so you might suspect that a tree does
not contain continuous straw like tubes
the tree effectively has vowels in it so
you don't have a column of water this
big tube what you're saying needs to be
filled with water it's actually made up
of cells although these are good
speculations they don't turn out to be
correct
scientists who study trees find that the
xylem tubes that transport water do
contain a continuous water column so how
else could the tree transport water from
the roots to the leaves they don't suck
they don't use a vacuum okay so how do
they do it wheezing like a cow like you
squeezing the cow letter all the way up
as little three muscles in there yeah
besides being a giant waste of energy
all of the cells that make up the xylem
tubes are dead what about osmotic
pressure if there is more solute in the
roots than in the surrounding soil water
would be pushed up the tree but some
trees live in mangroves where the water
is so salty that osmotic pressure
actually acts in the other direction so
the tree needs additional pressure to
suck water into the tree then it must be
capillary action
the thinner the tube the
the water can climb but the tubes in a
tree are too wide at 22 200 micro meters
in diameter water should rise less than
a meter so how do trees do it well one
of the assumptions we made is wrong the
lowest the pressure can go is if your
vacuum your vacuum your back in a gas
this is true when you eliminate all of
the gas molecules the pressure is zero
and you have a perfect vacuum but in a
liquid you can go lower than zero
pressure and actually get negative
pressures in a solid we would think of
this as tension this means that the
molecules are pulling on each other and
their surroundings as the water
evaporates from the pores of the cell
wall they create immense negative
pressures of minus 15 atmospheres in an
average tree think about the air water
interface at the pore there is one
atmosphere of pressure pushing in and
negative 15 atmospheres of suction on
the other side so why doesn't the
meniscus break because the pores are
tiny only two to five nanometers in
diameter at this scale water's high
surface tension ensures the air water
boundary can withstand huge pressures
without caving as you move down the tree
the pressure increases up to atmospheric
at the roots so you can have a large
pressure difference between the top and
the bottom of the tree because the
pressure at the top is so negative but
hang on if the pressure at the top is
negative 15 atmospheres shouldn't the
water be boiling yes yes it should but
changing phase from liquid to gas
requires activation energy and that can
come in the form of a nucleation site
like a tiny air bubble that's why it's
so important that the xylem tubes
contain no air bubbles and they can do
this because unlike a straw they've been
water filled from the start this way
water remains in the metastable liquid
state when it really should be boiling
it's just like supercooled water remains
liquid even though it should be ice so
you could say that the water in a tree
is super sucked because it remains
liquid at such negative pressures and
why are trees moving all this water up
the tree I want you to make a guess say
it out loud for photosynthesis actually
no less than 1% of the water is used in
photosynthetic reactions and
other ideas okay what about growth well
5% of the water is used to make new
cells so what happens to be other 95% of
the water it just evaporates for each
molecule of carbon dioxide that tree
takes in it loses hundreds of molecules
of water
whoa can you believe how amazing this is
trees create huge negative pressures of
tens of atmospheres by evaporating water
through nanoscale pores sucking water up
a hundred meters in a state where it
should be boiling but can't because the
perfect eylem tubes contain no air
bubbles just so that most of it can
evaporate in the process of absorbing a
couple molecules of carbon dioxide I
will never look at trees the same way
again
I'd like to say a huge thank you to Hank
Henry and professor Polyakov for making
on camera hypotheses this is an
essential part of the scientific process
even if your hypothesis turns out to be
wrong as Einstein said a person who has
never made a mistake has never tried
anything new but knows what I'd wondered
what it would be like to be on this side
now I'd be surprised if you weren't
already subscribed to these guys but if
you're not go click on these annotations
and check out their channels and you may
just learn something I'd also like to
thank professor John Sperry from the
University of Utah he walked me through
all of this in an hour-long Skype
conversation so I'm gonna put a link to
his website in the description we're
looking at pressures here below
atmospheric is that right that's right
this is a liquid pressure gas pressure
so it's a common misconception that oh
you can't have you know negative
pressures because there's no molecules
left you know the definition of pure
vacuum is zero molecules that's for a
gas okay so just just to be clear I
think this was one of my big big
problems in understanding this this
video would have been impossible without
CGP grey when I told him about this idea
in London and I felt like mine just
blown with this whole thing he said it
was gonna be really hard to explain and
you know when he says it's hard to
explain you know things are gonna be
tough so thank you for all your input
to this script and thank you for
watching making this video has been a
real Odyssey for me so thank you for
joining me on that journey I really
appreciate all of your comments and if
you haven't subscribed to the channel
already you can click the annotation or
click the link above and join me on my
next scientific adventure I made a video
promising to make a video about the
answer to this I proposed the problem
like right a couple months ago and I was
like subscribe to the channel I'll give
you the answer next week drive it at the
write through code Z